let's jump over to the first story trump
threatens to deploy
national guard to quell portland
protests from the military times they
say
president donald trump on thursday
threatened to deploy the national guard
to portland oregon if protests there
don't stop in the next few days
saying the violence has lasted for too
long so let's let me just i gotta do
this correction you know
don't put protest if you're complaining
about violence so he wants the riots to
stop
but then he said protesters so well
that's not a quote from him
right right well here's here's a quote
from trump these protesters
many should be arrested because these
are professional agitators these are
professional anarchists trump said
during a white house press conference
these are people that hate our country
we are telling them right now that we
are coming in very soon
the national guard a lot of very tough
people these are not people that just
have to guard the courthouse and save it
these are people who are allowed to go
forward and do what they have to do
at the peak more than 40 000 guardsmen
were activated across the country to
help deal with the protests sparked by
the death of george floyd
the use of guard troops to help with
violence on american soil is not unusual
but is typically done under the
direction
or with permission from state and local
officials in the case of portland
where protests have taken place every
night since may
the governor and mayor have objected to
the intervention of federal law
enforcement to address the issue
they don't know what they are doing
trump said of local leaders
and he's right yep they're trying to
declare victory like the feds are going
to leave
we got em guys riot still happened a
much smaller crowd
so it may die down now but i'm not
entirely convinced anyway
they say the oregon military department
told military times that the oregon
national guard
has not been requested or notified of
any request to respond to the situation
in portland at this time
and that's from major leslie reed the
department's deputy director of public
affairs this could just be trump
talking big it could be but maybe he
just hasn't drafted anything or told
anybody yet
the national guard bureau deferred
questions to the white house and
pentagon
pentagon officials did not immediately
respond to a request for comment
on thursday trump praised the
controversial presence
of homeland security personnel in
portland saying that the place was a
mess
and their deployment prevented hundreds
of millions of dollars in damage to the
federal courthouse
trump said those officers quote are
working today
and probably tomorrow to clean out this
beehive of terrorists in portland
if they do it i will be very happy he
said then slowly we can start to leave
the city
if they don't do it we will be sending
in the national guard
the president's announcement comes just
two days after congressional hearing
where a district of columbia army
national guard major who was working on
protest control during june 1st
demonstrations outside the white house
testified that federal agents were
overly aggressive in clearing out
peaceful protesters
major adam demarco said the guardsmen on
duty that day were left confused and
disheartened
by the actions with some members
questioning whether they had violated
the constitutional rights of free speech
and assembly
trump has voiced no such concerns saying
the protests were inspired by
non-violent ideals
but have since become little more than
an excuse for destruction in mayhem
they set a church on fire yeah yeah bill
barr
it's not just one they've sent well it
was uh was it st
john's is that the church i think so
yeah it's like the presidential church
yeah yeah yeah they torched they said
that uh could you could you look up this
guy
major adam demarco real quick yeah yeah
because i have i i think i saw some news
about him that provides context as to
why he's complaining but
i want to make sure we get it right he
might have a wikipedia page
yeah let me hold on let me find this see
if you can find it i mean trump nails it
right there
it he says and it's true it was inspired
by non-violent ideals
but those ideals have been lost with the
the violence that have happened it's
it's now an excuse to just
you know rock over statues and burn down
buildings and and small
businesses it's crazy so take a look at
this tweet from andy no
this is from the 30th at
12 28 p.m violent protests continued
overnight outside the portland federal
courthouse
rioters were more quickly repelled
because they lacked the huge crowds that
gave them better cover to commit acts of
violence
and we can see in this video there's
actually
far less people than normal wow yes a
lot of shields
and why is that where where'd everybody
go they went
they went home they went home they won
they beat they beat the feds
so the feds are still there yeah they're
the courthouse is still walled off with
fences we can see that
the feds have straight up said they
won't leave in fact trump is saying
we'll send the national guard in
why did they all disappear the big
question like i mentioned earlier will
be
if these protesters come out tonight
having seen the tear gas and the attack
on these you know antifa people
from state police not rights exactly
so here's what i think i think well
actually i tweeted it here's what i said
now that the people of portland would
have to protest their own democratic
governor it seems they didn't show up to
reinforce antifa
and far leftists when it was trump's
police
thousands were outraged now that it's a
democrat they don't care
what what happened all that talk about
the gestapo and trump's secret police
yep all right i'm not talking about that
in new york we got to be fair we got to
be fair these are
what's the governor's name kate brown
yeah kate brown secret police being
deployed to the streets
to attack peaceful protesters why adam
can
why are these democrats in your expert
opinion why the democrats sending out
unidentified secret police to brutalize
these peaceful demonstrators
well tim in my expert opinion i have no
idea
is it because kate brown is a fascist
yes
let's go with that okay confirmed
confirmed by my
expert opinion my opinion rather
it's expert did you find him i did find
him i haven't found anything interesting
about him and he doesn't have a
wikipedia page he doesn't yeah which is
really weird right
okay no that's fine that's fine he's
just a national guardsman yeah he's a
whistleblower i guess
they're kind of interesting yeah i
wonder i heard so much i heard some
people uh
talking about so so apparently some guy
came out
complaining about trump and barr
clearing out the uh the protest in front
of
the the the white house oh yeah yeah and
i just wanted to
check to see if there was anything
unifying anything so louis gohmert
questions his loyalty to the
democratic party no he questioned his
his
loyalty to the oath that he took to
become the attorney general
who uh i don't one of one of the
democrats and then the republican guys
in
in the testimony were like did you are
you going to let this side
you're talking about something else
louis gomer is a republican oh okay
and we're talking about the the national
guardsmen criticizing trump for clearing
demarco yeah so okay so noting his
unsuccessful run for
congress representative louis gomer from
texas told demarco his testimony quote
will serve you well with the democratic
party
close quote but he questioned his
loyalty to the military for opposing his
commander-in-chief's contention so
what you're saying is this demarco guy
ran for public office as a democrat
failed yeah he ran he tried to become a
democratic congress
congressman yeah there it is now he's
kind of that's right that's why
before i said anything before i said
anything i wanted just to just
have the source pulled up right why
would someone just come out and be like
these
these you know police clearing out these
peaceful demonstrations oh there it is
yeah he's a democrat yeah he ran for
office as a democrat look man
i get it you know there's a lot of
criticism they say trump went out and
did a photo op i had an argument with
some family members about it and i'm
like
it's it's it's such stupid it's it's so
dumb
okay you can't have months of violent
riots and protests and more importantly
if you ask a trump supporter why they
cleared out the area in you know
lafayette square they they had announced
they were clearing out at a certain time
already
right and bill bars had nothing to do
with trump doing a photo op
you're taking a photo in front of the
church and i'll tell you straight up you
know why donald trump went out and took
a photo holding a bible in front of the
church
to show the american public that we got
this under control boom
exactly yeah we put the fire out we
saved the church and we are still in
control of things
period right yeah it's like duh every i
wasn't even that
you know i i was entering my political
you know viewpoints at that moment of
time that was like what two months ago
now a month and a half
i'm not saying it was the right thing to
do morally i'm just saying
that's the reason and it's funny because
they they always try to
um make make it the worst of the worst
right yeah like the only reason trump
did it was for a re-election photo op
and i'm like that makes
no sense i mean if he wanted a photo of
him holding a bible in front of the
church he could have waited a day
yeah now what he did want to show is
that he's in control
because the church was just set on fire
and it's a historic church
so they took they took care of it what
did bill barr say when he was asked
this was great it was great so it was
good so attorney general bill barr is
testifying
and you have this one i guess i don't
know which guy what the guy's name who
asked him but he's like are you aware
that like the bishop and the priest or
whatever
you know condemned your cleaning of the
protests and he goes
was that before or after we put the fire
out oh
mike drop dude yelp bar was dropping
bombs
i'll tell you who they were like no no
no no uh reclaiming my time reclaiming
my time
don't let him speak i'll tell you too
many bombs i'll tell you who's being
political
it's the it's those though that priest
that bishop or whoever
yeah coming out attacking the president
when they literally had to
the fire trucks couldn't get through the
far left wanted the church to burn down
definitely i can't take these memes man
they don't talk about that side of it
it's only the fact that trump cleared
him out it's like well did you think
about
how they cleared them out so they could
put the church out the fire that was
burning this historical church it's
crazy information warfare you know
yeah it is it's like trying to like what
if people don't hear it they'll just
assume whatever the worst is
or whatever they're told so here's
here's what i see a lot
in these memes i've seen a ton of these
memes it's like
it said something like if save the
whales doesn't mean
f the fish then why do people get so
triggered by black lives matter
and i see this meme being shared by a
bunch of progressives and it says to me
they don't know
anything at all about black lives matter
and so i politely respond and i just say
i think a lot of people are upset
because
their movement on their website calls
for disrupting the nuclear family
like that's you know liberal and
conservative alike are going to be kind
of offended by that
some people won't care on both sides but
i think some people
see that and they're like i don't like
that and then they're like what do you
mean that's not what black lives matter
mean they get confused
well have you gone to the movement the
global movement's website and read their
doc because it says that
this is the patriarchy and down with the
nuclear family
yeah patriarchy gender norms western
family
and again i'm not i'm not i'm not saying
morally right or wrong i'm saying
here's a thing that makes people kind of
be like i don't like that
yeah and that's it but when you get your
news from memes
instead of actually asking the person
why they're upset guy
i hate meme news yeah that's all it is
man man
yeah that's what that's how the left
gets their news it really is
i mean and i say the left but it's it's
the left is more likely to get their
news from memes
and we all know the left can't meme
this is a proven fact that they cannot i
i learned it on uh
the internet so it's true you know
what's interesting is it's actually like
an 80
20 thing where like 80 of
of of the right has successful memes
okay
but memes live or die you know that's a
good point so they're good or they're
not
right and and the bad ones disappear and
the good ones move up
the the left it's like 80 of their memes
are trash
but they do every so often get something
good out
that works sure it does but this is why
they need to control
cultural institutions and media and you
know what conservatives are bad at
countering it it's a fact
how many how many yeah they're not on
the internet they're out there working
i mean they're on their phones more than
ever sure yeah it's playing nowadays
it's playing a big
big it's making you know has a big role
in this but i think when you look at
twitter when you look at youtube for
instance
and facebook you'll notice that
conservatives do ridiculously well on
all of these platforms
which says something the left is phantom
well yeah for sure absolutely i know the
left is comprised of people
who are being fed the news and just
mindlessly milling about
the right is people who are going on
social media sharing and engaging with
the news
yeah so if you're on youtube
and you go to a video of some like
left-wing issue you're going to see it's
thumbs down to oblivion
all the comments are angry like this is
garbage this is trash
then you go to like a moderate or
conservative and it's going to be more
thumbs up now it is true that a lot of
progressive youtubers get mostly thumbs
up
but they do have a higher density it
seems a thumbs down
for whatever reason i don't know but
typically you can predict what's going
to happen
gillette does a commercial where they're
like toxic masculinity must go
and then it's just down thumbs down into
oblivion maybe it's because
conservatives are more likely to share
news and liberals are more likely to
just share emotions
watch tv or see or share memes yeah you
know that's what i meant
that could be it i'm not entirely sure
but based on
my conversations man it is
you know when i'm talking to people who
are conservative they tend to have
understand references i'm making what
i'm like
so i'll be like this so so you heard
about what's going on in california with
with repealing civil rights oh yeah yeah
yeah that was on tucker was talking
about that
i'll be like yeah that's serious right
yep i'll talk someone on the left
and i'll say so are you familiar with
what's going on in california no
okay well what what's happening in
california they're repealing civil
rights
right that's what they'll say they're
not like wait what no i don't believe
you
no yeah look look it up online no
no that i know california that's that's
not them and that's good
send me a link about it every news story
is like affirmative action affirmative
action and not really telling you what
they're doing
right it's really it's really annoying
trying to break through the noise
but to people who are plugged in and
constantly searching and reading the
news
they understand the deeper context try
explaining obama gate
to your average lefty and they're going
to be like oh
this is crazy what are you talking about
that sounds nuts talk to a conservative
they're gonna be like oh yeah yeah cause
i heard about that
because you know a lot more
conservatives are a a lot higher on the
level of just hearing about it now
because they're just hearing about it
yeah they know about it that's kind of
what
what i mean is like if you've got the
the average right-leaning independent
yeah they've probably heard something
about
obamagate and something about spying and
unmasking well you said it i mean
they pay attention they're they're more
inclined to look for
like actual news instead of memes be
like oh this meme is news i pass it
online
look i'm going to say it again news whip
study
it's uh it tracked engagement and found
the left was primarily engaging with
occupy democrats
it is a meme page they're not real it's
not real news
and the conservatives were engaging with
fox news fox news is biased but it's
news
they have standards they have
corrections policy they're news guard
certified
and then you have i think the most
shared now is daily wire and ben shapiro
okay but the left is still memes memes
yeah and so i see like pictures of like
a black lives matter fist and it'll be
like
answer me this can serve a bros if this
then why not that and i'm like that's
that's what that's not news and no one
thinks that
they're all fake arguments yeah you know
it was here's a really funny one
i keep seeing this tweet be shared on
facebook between all these progressives
where they're like
answer me this you know trump supporters
where are all the 2a
libertarians saying you know that they
were going to stand up to government
tyranny
with with rifles yeah now now that
tyranny's happening in portland and i
sent him a picture of the boogaloo boys
showing up
showing up in portland and i'm like what
are you talking about they're right
there yeah they're literally right there
they're standing they didn't bring their
guns
yeah you know but they did show up and i
sent more pictures of the
boogaloo boys marching with black lives
matter and antifa
and then i'm like this meme is fake
somebody just
made it up stop sharing this part of the
problem is
these people on the left they have this
image of in their head
of like this bad guy the ultimate bad
guy
and it's like the biggest nazi
every hates everything that they're
about
and and they just apply that as a blank
like
slate over everybody that isn't in their
group so if
you vote for trump oh like that's
clearly you're this one person that i
have in my head this image of this bad
guy that i have
so that's like all their memes like well
riddled me this
bad guy that i have in my head where in
reality most people
aren't that person everyone's more in
the middle
looking at this looking at them like
you're crazy no one's like that that's
not the norm
why why do you think that why why is
your argument always against that one
person because that's not the norm
it's really simple uh this was noted i
think on sam harris's podcast and
when i was talking with jack dorsey on
rogan
conservative journalists will follow
liberals and conservatives
and liberal journalists only follow
liberals yep exactly jack did say things
were getting better and that was
starting to change i'm not sure where we
are at
where we're at now but that's the
easiest way to explain it
it's a one-way street if you're on the
right you're looking at everyone to your
left if you're on the left you're
looking at everyone to your left yeah
so they don't see what conservatives are
talking about they don't see the news
and they have no idea
it's crazy when i'll like tweet
something out that'll somehow find its
way into a left
journalism bubble and they're like what
are you talking about this is the
craziest thing i've ever heard that's
not true
and i'll be like did you not know this
happened like i'm just i'm just
like you know using a random news story
as an example i'll be like what do you
mean like it's
it's right here like reuters reported it
reported it yeah and they'll be like
oh i didn't see that yeah because you're
sitting in a toilet spinning around in
circles with all your buddies
and you're just like eating each other's
refuse it's like human centipede man
the funny thing is there's a meme going
around it's a sticker in new york city
that someone posted
and it's the human centipede but it's
trump and then a fox news reporter and
then a guy wearing a maga hat
what's funny about that is i get the
idea they're trying to convey
it's not true though it's fox news then
trump then trump supporter
not the way they had it yeah and the
other the other issue is that
trump is a symptom not the cause of so
it's actually not even true that it's
that trump you know trump is in the
front of the line if they want to play
this meme
up what was going on in this country was
going on for a long time
what was going on with the culture war
and and social justice and pc was
happening well before trump
trump came about and was voted in partly
because of all of these things
he is a symptom of our current state of
affairs in this country not the creator
of it they don't understand that
they blame trump for it no if everything
was
normal if jobs were here if people were
happy there wouldn't be a donald trump
he came in because he specifically said
look at these things
he talked about trade and he made fun of
you know rosie o'donnell and other
people
well andy called out the establishment
in a very specific way that
i'm tending to lean on the fact that
it's it's pretty true i mean a lot of
the stuff that he's was talking about
we're we're finding proof and they're
talking about it and now
there were subpoenas are being issued
it's going to be a really interesting
fall
they've been they've been selling
selling us out to multinational
corporations
everybody knows it it's like every
activist has been talking about it
everyone was complaining about it
so when you got bernie sanders and trump
very early on talking about the tpp
nafta and immigration you had left and
right-wing populists being like
here we go yep bernie sanders however
said let me tow the establishment line
being a millionaire sounds fun
and donald trump was like i'm already
rich i don't care i'm gonna do whatever
i want and give away
my giveaway my yearly salary but
he gets a bounce he spent they spend way
more money on trump than his yearly
salary
so he's giving away a salary i get it
same with every president whatever
that's
that's true sure sure but i'm just kind
of like
to be honest you know it's four hundred
thousand dollars presidents get rich off
their books and appearances
you know their salary is whatever i'm
not gonna write that off i think that's
awesome
yeah no it's true i agree i agree i'm
not saying it's i'm not i'm not dragging
him for it's a good thing he did it
yeah i'm just like a lot of people want
to act like it's the biggest thing ever
it's good trump is a billionaire but i
respect it you know what i mean yeah
like sure
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you